so that just set the president for your
channel then it's like okay we went to
North Korea uh that kind of like what's
next
did you make the channel remind me like
I want to get political and talk about
it kind of have opinions and things yeah
I think that was that was the the goal
of it um kind of try to make politics
funny try to try to brainwash people who
don't want to hear anything about
politics
yeah because I saw the video where it
was like how how much money can you
launder in there yeah
it's awesome really fun one there's this
guy um Troy stalls he's like a
whistleblower
um he's a dude who used to work for the
the gambling I guess gambling industry
to like check if they're
um doing what is it if they're complying
with money laundering regulations in
Australia yeah yeah yeah it turns out
all these casinos aren't they're like
actively letting money laundering happen
because they make money from it and you
know yeah all this stuff and he reveals
this and then they like through the [__]
out of him and like this guy's like
getting [__] up I'm sorry yeah yeah
we've done it um
and like this guy's getting screwed in
here I don't know it was a very very sad
situation so we like kind of came in and
got him to show us how you launder money
in a casino yeah and just how easy it is
it's incredibly it's crazy it's so easy
that you just you go to a poker machine
you put in as much money as you want
take notes because
then you hit a button and it will just
give you a receipt which you can take up
to the counter and they will give you
clean bills not only clean bills but a
receipt that says you won this from
gambling and then there's tax free money
yeah well it's tax free and you can do
it on a on a on a thing up to seven
thousand dollars and you can do that
onto multiple machines so we easily did
like twenty five thousand dollars in you
know in in like two three hours but the
thing is we won't even just we at first
we were just seeing if we could do it
and it was fine then after that we're
like oh if it's this easy like maybe
pull up the stakes and we're just
wearing different costumes like you yeah
the shirts or like I'm laundering money
right now yeah like dressed as like a
robber in there it was just like it
doesn't matter like they don't care oh
my God have you ever been contacted by
like the authorities or anything yeah we
got banned from the casinos in Australia
for a different reason for another video
where you uh because I guess during
covid you were seeing if they were
complying with covert rules yeah and
then you went in with a fever yeah
you hit you heat up your arm when we had
a hats on and we put heat packs under
the hat so and then we took off the hats
just before so they didn't see the heat
packs yeah right and my head was
something around 50 degrees
Yeah Yeah and they kind of scanned our
heads and then we're like oh just wait
here for a minute and then they did that
and then just let us in with like 50
degree fevers are you wearing like a
hospital yeah Alexis down with like a
drip yeah
I'm like yeah yeah I did but I'm feeling
lucky you know
I would just like oh I just get changed
first and then you can go in yeah that
was it it's just so [__] insane and
then recently I had the police come to
my mom's house
um oh wait after that we got banned from
the casino oh yeah all right conclusion
contact us why did you get back sorry
why did you uh the police get called to
your mom's house it was because of a
video I made five years ago I made a um
a gun I don't like saying oh my God
the device that's prepared yes a
propelling device that propelled tampons
um so it was like a Nerf propeller yeah
that shot tampons and I made it five
years ago and it was horrible it didn't
work well at all I said wait why do they
give a [__] about that because they came
and they were telling my mom they were
just like oh it's so dangerous what Alex
has done because what if like the bike
he's got a hold of it or someone else
got a hold of it and it was just like
the bikies have real guns yeah like what
are they going to do with this so
tampons cost like a million dollars a
cheaper
and it didn't work very well I almost
felt like telling them like no I could
make much better things now
wait so how did that go then so yeah
image explaining to your mom and then
they just left so I didn't I I destroyed
the device very quickly after making it
so luckily I didn't have it
um and then they just kind of they were
pretty chill about it there were two
female cops which was very funny that
they were looking for the tampon
but then they they just said like oh if
he has has it there's a thing in
Australia called a gun amnesty so if you
make a device or you have a unregistered
firearm you can give it into the police
without questions right
um I don't have the device I like I'm
saying this a lot dude
and then so then they'll I just told
them um that I didn't have the device
anymore and they were happy right so
yeah I don't have it yeah so I'm sure
you would know this best but what like
technically is like the definition of a
gun in the eyes of the Australian law
it's pretty vague in terms of it's like
is my opinion of it like I thought
foreign
I thought it was something that needed a
trigger
um then that uses any kind of anything
to project something right yeah yeah but
it turns out it's not that you don't
need a trigger it's just anything that
projects anything out of a everything
okay so it's like so Nerf gun a Nerf gun
was a gun so it's like an air rifle is a
gun and a blue a blue a blow gun right
what is a gun
you're projecting something it's insane
rules yeah
um so it's like yeah so so where do they
draw the line how much is it very
intentional yeah to just kind of crack
down whoever they want to know exactly
probably because if you look up what's
illegal here like nunchucks or legal
throwing stars released knives so it a
lot of the stuff you've got that big
nunchuck massacre in Tasmania
well nunchucks are illegal in a lot of
places actually oh yeah why what they
just hurt yourself
I swear I was going to buy them on
wish.com one time and I like live and
people were like no don't do that I was
like it's two planks of wood yeah how is
this like who I I can own a knife I feel
like politicians just watched one too
many Bruce Lee yeah yeah
if he can do that anyone can do that
also obviously there's obvious reasons
are illegal I I would say that makes
more sense
I think nunchucks are like probably more
dangerous right I mean if you know how
to use it if you're not to use it you
know if you know how to use it brush
Knuckles are made for just beating
people up like yeah no no okay if if I'm
in a street fight and someone brings out
some [__] nunchucks I'm getting the
[__] up that means they're not dangerous
because if someone actually pulls them
out and does a trick you'll be like this
guy's serious I'm leaving yeah brass
knuckles they're hidden until someone
hits you in the face with them yeah yeah
that's true but that you know it's
because nunchucks have a skill ceilings
so I'm like if someone brings out I'm
like I'm getting out nunchucks in a
fight if they weren't competent that's
what I'm saying though that's what I'm
saying that's my exact point
yeah you know brass knuckles you know
you know how brass knuckles works you
know nunchucks I have no idea how the
[__] that works so speaking of fighting
you both also were going to fight
so you were in the first crater clash
and you were going to do the second one
yeah unfortunately you got a concussion
and you were going to do chest boxing
against me and then you've got a
concussion as well but you gave him a
concussion
he [__] me up we just sound like the
biggest idiots
the worst part about um when Alex Alex
knocked me out it was um we were
sparring all the time and um at one
point like five weeks before the match
because he's just a big big and strong
guy Alex and he yeah he punched me like
in the chest and he broke one of my ribs
and it was like it was five weeks out
from the thing and I looked it up online
it's like okay it takes five weeks for a
broken web to heal like I'm in this I've
still got it yeah it's like we can keep
training but no more body shots just
headshots just headshots and then like
pseudo lady just knocked me out and it's
just like okay so headshots aren't safe
yeah it's just it's such a dumb bought
that like I mean there's obviously ways
to train relatively safe but at the end
of the day it's like you're just getting
hit in the head yeah yeah it's just and
then when it happened to me I was like
this isn't worth it right I'm scared the
crap it's [__] scary and he he was
bad like we had it where we were having
a party at the house and um he wasn't
drinking at all because he was concussed
and I went to the bathroom came back and
then Alexa was talking to some people
but he was just kind of talking
gibberish and he sounded really drunk
and I was like oh Alex is [__] he's so
drunk and I was like wait he's not
drinking I was like he's just that good
ass I was scared for a while though it's
like first couple of weeks where I was
like slowing my words I was I thought
like it's just the rest of my life
um
you just get punched and how long does
it last like what like this this was
like two months of non-stop Jesus um
that's not worth it [__] that yeah you
know
dangerous because so many people are
into the Creator boxing so now and we
don't really know how [__] up
everyone's gonna be because we're
professional fighters yeah when they're
50 or 60 they just can't speak we
haven't had like a proper debilitating
injury yet I know a short one's gonna
happen some creators gonna get like
messed up forever like yeah when you get
one concussion getting a second one it's
way easier yeah yeah
and I guess because everyone's not
really a professional fighter which even
is a professional no just someone who's
been concussed 100 times like you know
yeah it seems pretty rough I mean some
of the fights look pretty bad afterwards
yeah you see people who are pretty
[__] up yeah oh God no yeah we were
making videos like two days ago why are
we yeah you already have a career like
yeah you're not trying to be a
professional boxer yeah but it must have
been some kind of like [__] I wish I
could have fought in that though that's
the thing is it's real love hate where
it's like just the ultra competitiveness
and the real nature of it is just
something else like it almost feels like
it activates this kind of Primal part of
your brain like when I had it it was
just like no thoughts just focusing on
kill man
with this weird like part of your brain
it's fun to be there for a bit how long
do you train for the first grader Clash
I think I was training for like maybe
seven months six months and there's a
lot of like the sparring was terrifying
like doing like because I'd I'd been in
fights but never thrown a punch before
that where it was just like mates being
[__] in a bar and then yeah but it
was always like the option was like if
someone's gonna punch me you run away
without having to sit stand in a ring
and face big guy that wants to punch you
who knows how to punch it's like the
most the scariest thing how hard did you
go in training compared to like the
actual event itself because if you can
get concussion training that you
obviously are going pretty [__] hard
yeah my trout wolf for me because my
fight I didn't get punched
I'm gonna try to use much much worse
punched over and over and over again
you're like oh this is easy mode now
someone's the first one how long were
you training for the chess boxing more
that wasn't that long it was like three
and a half months that's still a long
time yeah it was great though I love
like because I've never been a athlete
yeah it is pretty nice to have that kind
of um regimented life have like a big
goal and like have someone on the other
side of the world who wants to beat the
[__] out of you like it's such a good
motivator to do anything
I want to get myth to beat me up just
for like just for cleaning my [__]
together
for making a video oh yeah I gotta make
a video yeah because you guys ever do it
yeah no hell no maybe I mean after after
hearing these stories
I feel like it's just like a good excuse
to get in shape yeah obviously the
biggest reason yeah but you can do that
without getting punched in the headers
yeah but like sometimes it's called
going to the gym but what better
motivation is there than like the danger
of getting hit in the [__] audience
you know that is that is the best
motivator you can have been more
motivated in my life you want to be that
guy who loses in the first round right
like that's a powerful motivator yeah to
get you to [__] train I I would have
liked to have done it but
um yeah I have like a blood condition so
no one will allow me to and also I
shouldn't because I'm it'd be dumb what
you went training for the slap boxing
that you did no I I just [__] went up
and did that that was like last minute
yeah yeah because what you were it was
meant to be xqc or something oh yeah
yeah you remember right because we were
there yeah because I remember I was
pissing and he was like I don't know who
I'll ask you know I was like I might ask
Alex and I was like I don't mind doing
it as well like I was like I was for
sure so that was all last minute but you
were great I like your stage presence up
there I was just like he looks like this
is WWE
awesome
that's very nice of you yeah I was so
[__] last minute you know just kind
of was like all right let's we were
sitting together yeah yeah drinking
beers and then suddenly the production
comes up to me he's like are you ready I
was like go ahead two hours to go up and
I started shooting myself [__] I came
here to like hang out and just like have
a good time and drink beers and then I
and then I have to go out but it was fun
though it was definitely a good time
yeah I didn't expect to go up at all
since you were training for the chess
boxing uh because I talked to like a
bunch of creators who were part of the
chess boxing event and there seemed to
be a disparity between how much training
you put into boxing versus how much
people putting into the chess aspect of
things did you actually like practice
any chess style I love chess like um
my dad's like a competitive chess guy
um so like I've been your dad's like
1400 isn't it oh wow yeah he's a he's a
big guy well inboxing
he beats you as well
one of the queen that was my kind of
secret weapon I've been right well
myth's chest was [__] awful awful
yeah
you could have won with a concussion I
think yeah
and the best thing about that was
hearing that Ludwig had lied to you
about me but then Ludwig had liked a
myth about you myth thought you were six
one yeah you're actually six three and
what you thought he was I thought I
thought he was shorter than he was and
um I thought some uh Ludwig told me that
he was like almost like 10 kilograms of
lighter and then you both found out at
the same time and you're both like right
we look at each other we're like wait a
minute
very very funny so no no no more boxing
I don't think so I think I'm done unless
there's someone that's just like a
ridiculously easy
I actually hate for some reason I feel
like boxing if you actually hate someone
then you'd be like well there's a
purpose here but you hear boxes be like
oh you want a box of friends it's like
why do you want to give a friend a
concussion no no you should box someone
you hate yeah a lot of those matches are
like they're friends of each other and
it's like no like me and Fitz and I
think that would have been like a [__]
up fight like yeah we're both lanky he's
like six foot six I think it would have
just been both of us being really badly
but also you guys are like in love with
each other which is like yeah one of you
is going to go less hard one of you is
not going to be able to be that angry
yeah like they're doing Bruno at the end
we were talking about that
just start having sex
sex
in Florida as well
I mean they [__] sing the national
anthem yeah yeah
oh
yeah maybe maybe something that's a
great perfect great yeah it was fancy
yeah yeah good way to launcher
[Music]
money's getting low we gotta find it
let's let's get it out